poland's second city looks different
these days
soldiers on scooters
refugees on sidewalks
reminders of russia's war in ukraine
at the consulate in krakow hundreds of
ukrainians wait in line for hours every
day
what's happening in ukraine is awful
it's war shooting killing they don't
hesitate to kill anybody it's mentally
very difficult my mind just cannot take
i think that it will take a long time
before it's over lots of people will die
this is horrible
recently arrived are part of the
diaspora for ukrainians uncertainty and
chaos
have become the norm
getting passports having documents
attested the drudgery of life admin
taking on much more significance now as
many ukrainians prepare to be away from
home for an unknown period of time
poland has never seen an influx of so
many refugees so quickly
krakow's mayor says the city has its
limits
you know i think i'm seeing it the same
as every citizen of the city it's a
major challenge the most important thing
is humanitarian aid no matter what we
are trying to do whatever we can this
war is something really terrifying
public housing for refugees is near
capacity the mayor says his city needs
more government funds to keep helping
people
for now the fate of many is in the hands
of hard-working volunteers at charities
throughout the country
donations keep coming around the clock
volunteers working throughout the night
to pack supplies most headed for kiev
the besieged ukrainian capital
for sierra originally from ukraine this
is personal
the second floor of this charity has
been turned into a temporary shelter for
mostly women and children the biggest
challenge he says is finding people a
place to sleep in the beginning people
only slept here for one night and then
left now they're staying for three or
four nights we're looking for places for
them to go the government promised help
but we don't know if that's going to be
enough
cities like krakov are dealing with wave
after wave of refugees and with
worsening violence in ukraine there's no
hiding from the fact they won't be going
home
time soon zain vs ravi al-jazeera krakow
poland
the un's warning the war in ukraine
could lead to a global food catastrophe
half of the grain used by the world food
programme comes from ukraine the u.n
says 821 million people around the world
suffer from hunger russia and ukraine
combined provided nearly a third of the
world's wheat and barley exports wheat
prices have jumped by 55
since the week before the invasion and
russia has put a temporary ban on
exporting grain and sugar
shazam
is a communications officer at the world
food programme and she says the war is
having a significant knock-on effect on
global food supplies
i think the main challenge at the moment
are the infrastructures and supply chain
systems
uh that are falling apart i mean these
systems are supposed to be feeding
millions of people that are trapped in
the conflict in ukraine and uh some of
them are completely decimated so we're
talking about uh trucks and trains that
are being destroyed bridges falling
apart
uh supermarkets that are being wiped out
and
we're having to build this operation
from the grounds up
and this you know to build such an
operation is going to take a lot of time
which is unfortunately not on our side
but our priority is to focus on
repairing those uh infrastructures and
supply chain system and creating this
supply chain lifeline into kiev so that
we could facilitate the transportation
of humanitarian assistance not just food
but on behalf of the humanitarian
community but also pre-position
food stocks in areas where we feel the
conflict may flare up there are so many
countries and regions that depend on
exports from ukraine but for example the
mena region is one that's going to be
impacted you've got lebanon they export
50 percent uh they import 50 of their
wheat from ukraine tunisia 42 percent
and yemen uh 22
so it's definitely going to have a
ripple effect